and understanding the creative and the
blessing
that god has put inside of each one of
us through our biology
it makes sense that mentally or
psychologically we may
separate from the intention of god that
he gave to us in our identities and our
bodies but god can bring it all back
together
sex education how young is too young
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness welcome to led
live where we are gonna use the light of
christ to expose some darkness
today's topic might be a little
sensitive
but uh we're going to talk about sex
education welcome mike
thank you you've been on our show before
so if you haven't seen some of his
videos
um maybe click through some of our old
videos we'll put the links on there
below
but um thank you and welcome back thanks
good to be here
this is uh going to be an interesting
topic yeah i want to know this
information because
as as as we are all parents at the table
here
um i mean when is it appropriate to talk
to your kid about sex that's
that's kind of i think a general
question for young parents
it's interesting because um i think a
lot of the times the questions that we
get a lot
a lot is about whether our presentations
are appropriate for children
and if they share it with their children
how old do their children have to be
uh to benefit from the program without
being instructed on
sexuality but what is the foundation and
so this has been a question
in my mind before as long as we've been
in ministry
for those who don't know what is your
ministry real quick sure
coming out ministries uh is a 10-year
anniversary this year and
we're celebrating not only talking about
the lgbt
issue which all of my colleagues and i
have experienced but it's
gotten much broader since the moment
that we began uh
talking about sexuality people would
come up and say you know i'm not gay but
i certainly relate to what you're
talking about
we realize now that it's a present truth
talking about sexuality identity which
are all the things that the world is
screaming about
so coming out ministries is really i
think morphed into something much
broader talking about sexual purity
so again you know we get invited to
schools to academies
universities colleges pastors retreats
women's retreats singles retreats
and unfortunately i think one of the big
misnomers about coming out ministries is
is that we're going to expose children
to sexuality that they're not ready for
um
what i really find blinding about the
church today is that they don't even
have a clue
that their children are already on
youtube and all of these
social networks and they are much more
educated than even
adults are or being taught in school oh
absolutely
sure there's an agenda even in school
which has
come into life more recently and coming
out ministries
uh recognizes that now we have school
systems
in countries around the world that are
mandatory to
have that in their education system as a
matter of fact i'm glad you brought that
up
i was recently in europe and in some of
the european countries
it's mandatory to have sex educators
come into the school
and they usher the students or the
teachers out and they leave only the
students
and the sex educators speak directly to
the children wow
talking about masturbation homosexuality
uh
identity and these kind of things now
why would you not want the teacher there
that's right because it's awkward
is the teacher going to stop you or
something i don't know i think you know
so that the children aren't inhibited by
the teachers opinions or thoughts that
makes sense like
so they'll feel more free to ask right
yeah i mean i've always heard in our
ministry we talk a lot about technology
and stuff and
and a lot of times when we speak people
will say well well what age is
appropriate for your kid to have a phone
and i've always heard it say 47 well no
i've always i've always heard it say
the second that you're you're willing to
let your child look at pornography yeah
wow
i mean it's like whoa whoa whoa because
it's only a matter of time
before you know a young person actually
has the device
and if it can be connected to
pornography in some way they will get
exposed to it
at some point uh you have options you
don't have to give them a smartphone
that's right a flip phone yes a
smartphone actually that i should
clarify
that was dealing with when should my
child have a smartphone because he has a
flip phone
you know not necessarily a problem any
child that has access
to uh unlimited internet is like giving
a razor blade to a baby
it's just the way it is that's how how
pervasive the important uh
issue is in our world today and for a
parent to be as
reckless to give their child a
smartphone uh at any age
in my opinion without parameters or
controls on it is
you're basically feeding into the
destruction of your child's absolutely
and as a church we should never be
in a position of playing catch-up that's
right you know with the world or
you know when we put our children out
there whether it's school giving them a
phone or anything like that
the education should come from us
internally before they go out
perfect because that's why this program
um i designed it to be
educational about when do you start
implementing that education to your
children and
when is too late you know when is it too
late before
they've already heard things from the
world and from the educators of the
schools
and i think that it's important to start
that dialogue from the moment
they can understand simple concepts and
in sabbath school we have that
you know they talk about the ark and
they put rainbow on the wall and they
have all of the stuffed animals
in this you know this makeshift arc and
they start talking about these stories
but i don't think that we have really um
drained all of the truth that's in those
simple stories that we give in cradle
role
when we could really start to affirm
identity and sexuality
even from the creation story that's
right
so if i could that's why i have this
program called who
am i and uh basically talking about uh
identity and sexuality there's a quote
that i have from
um thoughts from the amount of blessings
page 138
it says in the road to death the whole
race may go
with all their worldlyness with all
their selfishness their pride dishonesty
and moral debasement there is room for
every man's opinion
and doctrine space to follow his
inclinations to whatever his self-love
may dictate
in order to go in the path that leads to
destruction there is no need of
searching for the way for the gate is
wide
and the way is broad and the feet
naturally turn
into the path that ends in depth and so
as i've been
you know doing this ministry stuff for
10 years it's important
for me to um not only to find out
why i also was transgendered even at my
first conscious thought
and how to talk about addressing that in
a sympathetic and a compassionate way
but i have parents that also come to me
talking about how their
their sons or their daughters uh they
think of maybe struggling with
transgenderism or homosexuality
and to approach that in a biblical way
and also in a way that can actually draw
them into
god's ideal i think is real important
and so now you know we have
these books i put up this image of
jacob's new dress
as one of the books that is designed to
teach preschoolers
so even before your children get to
school they're already
educating your children on identity and
sexuality and how fluid that can be
and how old are you when you started um
questioning your sexuality great
question because
i had my very first conscious thought
was i'm in the wrong sex
and i don't know how i communicated that
to myself but
that was this big conflict and i think
that that's what became this obsession
for me
as a little boy at four years old i just
knew that i wasn't like my sisters but i
wasn't like the boys in school
and i completely felt isolated in my
identity
and then i was reminded by the boys that
i didn't measure up because they called
me queer and
but then as much as i tried to imitate
and emulate my mother and my sisters
i knew that i didn't match them either
so i was really trapped in this
um purgatory of identity but i couldn't
deny the fact that i was drawn towards
playing with dolls
i wanted to wear the pretty dresses you
know boys shoes were only brown or black
and the girls had these really pretty
purses and beautiful dresses so
that was where my focus was and i don't
remember it ever being anything
different
so that's also why i bought into the
narrative that i was born this way
how could i have come up with those
thoughts on my own right so i asked that
because a lot of the testimonies that
i've heard
um people who have those struggles start
young or they identified with that young
whether they're gay transgender or
whatever the case
so i'm wondering where the problem is
really coming from is it that the child
can't understand the concept or it's the
parent
who's gone through life maybe seen the
struggles of people like that or
i don't know have maybe a confused
understanding of sexuality themselves so
it's like
really the adults projecting onto the
kids or maybe they're not understanding
the innocence of the kids to understand
simple concepts
well candy that that takes a lot of
unpacking and we did that in the
transformed um
program that we did hopefully they're
flashing it under the screen somewhere
but if you could even watch that program
in conjunction with this one
i think that that really helps to answer
some of those questions
not only from my own personal experience
but also from
the experience of marissa and ray as we
talked about before them so we have
a lot of those but i also want to talk
about the fact let me go back
here this is another pre-school book
talking about my princess boy loves his
dad
and his dad tells him how pretty he
looks in a dress his dad holds his hand
and tells him to twirl my princess boy
smiles and hugs his dad all of this is
designed
to to change the way that we think about
identity and sexuality
and to plant those seeds in young
impressionable minds you see
as a child i didn't know the difference
between fantasy
and reality i also didn't know what my
favorite color was it changed from day
to day
so when you tell a child that doesn't
know the difference between fantasy and
reality that they can change their sex
they can change their identity you are
planting within them
these seeds of um confusion
and also uh unrestrained identities
that i think are really going to have a
a huge impact on our world in
in just a few years i think this really
speaks to the power
of a book though i mean this is almost
like
proof in the pudding that they're
sitting there saying hey look if we just
actually
incorporate these ideas into little kids
books we can actually change
the mindset down the road and it's like
for anybody that's like oh whatever it's
just entertainment or it's just a book
or whatever so
this is how people you know learn things
right right so how many times your
children come to you and daddy read this
book and you're like i've read that 14
times
already today right but that's the power
of what that influence has and
and what implants a principle more than
when your mother or father the most
important people in your life are
reading that to you and affirming that
to you yeah that's even that even brings
up a whole different
can of worms here because it's like if
your parent
if you're a parent and you're reading i
mean whatever sorcery magic whatever
you're
you're kind of putting that stamp of
approval on that subject well that's
what you read to me when i was a kid dad
i thought it was okay that's interesting
so it it
for me you know the neuroscience really
comes to mind you think about mirror
neurons and particularly in your case i
think this is striking because where's
the father figure
right so what do kids do they're
biologically wired to
do what they see and in your case
what you see you're surrounded by all
women
yeah so that that's what you're that's
the behavior that you start
modeling and and so they did this so i'm
gonna do this and they did that and i'm
gonna do that
and so that i think is
why you know god has put um
both parents i know as a parent like of
you know i have a little girl and i have
three boys if i go
to work on something at home my boys
they start looking for tools and they're
gonna fix something
why because dad was doing it you know so
whatever you're doing
your child is modeling and that's why i
always tell people you know if you want
him to go to church
you want him to read your bible you want
him to pray you need to do all those
things
sure absolutely so in
england alone there's a thousand percent
increase now on transgenderism among
children
and they're not moving children to
embrace their biology
they're indulging these children to
embrace what's in their mind
what was that number what was that one
thousand percent
increase on transgenderism wow
absolutely
so the program that i have that um i was
speaking at an academy that had a
kindergarten through sixth grade and the
things that i share with the
the teenagers are not appropriate to
share with young people
and i understand the challenges
especially for parents today you know
how young
is too young to expose them to identity
and sexuality
so we were just going to leave out this
age group and i thought no wait if we
have books that are
targeting our young children even before
they go to school
we should be doing this even before they
get to school as well we should be doing
the same things and i believe that we
can do that
in cradle roll in primary classes in
kindergarten as our children are
developing
but we have to be a little bit more
intentional we have to make sure
you know how many colors the rainbow has
when you paint it in your sabbath school
class and
you know not just talking about that
they went into the art two by two
and we'll discuss that a little because
i want to kind of go through this
program
so basically on the first day with the
children i decided that um
that if they gave me just a half an hour
with young kids because their attention
span is pretty short
so you want to make it simple and then
every day you can kind of like build on
things that you've learned the day
before and the whole idea
is to affirm to them god's
intentionality and then we
end on day five with god's love and his
compassion
towards each one of us because again i
thought that god
rejected me and i thought that he was
playing a joke on me that he made me a
boy and not a girl
so i think it's most important to end
with god's affirmation of each one of us
so let me go through this just a little
bit so on day one i basically asked the
kids am i a zebra of course they say no
am i a giraffe am i a dog am i a cat and
of course
you know kids are so simplistic and you
can use this very quickly and they go
now and they all shut out now and i said
girls and boys that was what we are
and then i go to the bible genesis
chapter 1 and verse 27
that god created man in his own image in
the image of god created he him
male and female now using this as an
opportunity to affirm to the kids that
listen
you're the image of god it's not that
you're a giraffe or a dog or a cat
you were created in the image of god and
he did that through
two kinds and what was that male and
female so i say okay all the boys stand
up and the boys jump up you know and
kids love anything that's expressive
physically you know so you get them
involved you
help them to understand the principles
at their level that they can relate to
so the boys jump up and they're all you
know kind of like knocking around or
whatever and standing up there and then
i go oh
if your girl stand up so then the guys
drop you know and the girls
instantly stand up and they laugh and
the you know the room was full of um
you know a lot of animation and so again
just getting them to understand those
differences
so then genesis chapter 1 and verse 10
creation was good
but when god created man and woman
together right he stood back and he said
this is very good genesis 1 31.
why was it so good why was it different
than the creation days
because god implanted his very image
in the relationship between a male and a
female now
you don't want to share with your kid
any more than they're able to handle and
you certainly don't want to teach them
about sex
but you can tell them that the the
relationship between one man
and one woman like mommy and daddy was
the
express image of god in the creative
process of the two of them together
and that this was very good so again we
go through a little checklist how many
kinds of people did god create
to a man and a woman together right and
then god told e
adam that eve was to be his wife and
marriage was created in the garden of
eden and again
all you're doing is you're affirming
god's principle that one man
and one woman in a relationship together
boom very simple right
so then god then told adam and eve to be
fruitful and multiply and you don't have
to go through the steps
but you want to be honest with your
children you don't want to say that you
were found under a cabbage patch
yeah or that the store brought you in
because just like the santa store
exactly
that's right and then you're not
credible anymore exactly you are not a
credible um example of someone that i
can get answers from
right now i know when my kids were
younger uh my daughter in particular was
one to ask
more questions and it was like how did
we
how did how did we get here and you know
she told her well
you know it takes a mommy and daddy and
god made a way you know it was a very
simplistic uh but age-appropriate answer
perfect teeth it's really perfect my
daughter knows that you know when a
woman is pregnant that's the baby in
there and
and that they come out she knows where
they come out at but
she doesn't know how they get in and
she's never really asked she's 10.
so yeah you'd be surprised maybe
the information's been volunteered time
to sit down
[Laughter]
you're taking the route my mom took
she's like oh you never asked so i never
like really discussed it with you
i learned it very scientifically in
biology so maybe this is a good time
to kind of share this one story that
really impacted me and my colleague
to the point where we were in tears you
know what do you give your kids and i
think that that's a good principle if
they're not asking
why give them more information than what
they're ready for we were speaking at
a pastor's retreat and we were doing a
question and answer for all of the
pastor's wife
and this woman who who was very
conservative and a big fat smile on her
face and after we were done she came up
to us and she goes
oh i understand everything that you were
saying and i'm looking at her and i'm
thinking
lady i don't think you have a clue you
know what we've been through and she
just started to explain she said you
know when i was a young girl
i said to my mother mother i want to see
a naked man
and that's exactly what anyone else was
you're like whoa
but the mother did not respond with
shock
but instead she said well i don't really
have a naked man to show you
i guess we could ask your father and the
daughter you know she said oh no no no i
don't want to see father naked
so the mother didn't overreact and the
minute that you
overreact you've lost your ability to be
objective
and the child can feel judgment or
rejection from that or fear
that maybe what i'm saying is wrong and
then they start worrying about can i say
this to my mom
so we have to be very careful about our
reactions but the mother reacted in such
a beautiful way
and she said well you know men are
hairier than women
men have more muscles than women and and
and like you said
she gave her just enough information
that she was asking for and that was it
and that seemed to suffice so this this
young girl was growing up she had
younger brothers and sisters
she was cleaning out a house you know as
a church mission project
opens a cabinet door and finds a poster
a centerfold of a naked man
you know a lumberjack and that's all
i'll say so she pulls the
picture off and she hides it from her
brother and sister but what do you think
she did with that
mom she went to her mother who was a
trusted source and she goes
look mother a naked man and the mother
again you know
i shot i didn't react like oh that's
disgusting and oh you're terrible for
looking at that
instead she said well you've always
wanted to see a naked man and there he
is
and then she went through an anatomy
course and they discovered wasn't i
right
he's got more hair than than we do he's
got more muscles than women do
but once she affirmed all of the
physical attributes
i love this she said but look at his
face what's he doing
well he's smiling mother and she said
what do you think he's smiling about
i don't know do you think he loves jesus
do you think he's a christian
do you think he's married do you think
he holds the door open for his
wife and then the tears started coming
down my face as i realized
that this mother was was what's the word
for very realistic
and very clinical about something that
was very dirty and disgusting but she
didn't shame her daughter and instead
she did the checklist of the anatomy
but then she took it to the spiritual
aspect and what was so amazing is what a
lesson that was
to teach our children that they can come
to us with anything at any time
and that they'll get a legitimate answer
and that the mother and father has an
opportunity to make it a spiritual
application
and that was such a beautiful story to
me i wish
that it could have honestly gone to my
mother my father and just shared
that was struggling with this identity
inside that nobody wanted
that i seem to be drawn to and if i
could have had those answers at a very
young age and if my parents had the
tools
i might have had a different reality and
so that's also the idea
of this program teaching your children
young that they can come to you and that
you're trusted
but not just that for them to also think
for themselves ask themselves questions
not just see something and maybe react
or ingest it let's really ask and
walk through is it something good is it
something bad paints a bigger picture
than just
what's in front of them i like that the
end result was really to focus on
on you know the the yeah the thoughts
and the mind and
what's this person like and not just
like the physical outside of somebody
yeah instead of just being like oh he's
attractive man i'd marry him
well would you i mean how's he really
going to treat you it's more than just
looking nice you know or whatever yeah i
like that thing
sure sure there's so many aspects and
you can start at the youngest age and
then as time grows
you know goes on you're you're teaching
your children even more principles about
that
so again the family is a blessing from
god all of this was in the garden of
eden when it was perfect before sin
even entered mothers and fathers
brothers and sisters
sons and daughters so there's a
distinction between the two kinds but
there's definitely
different definitions of that even jesus
was given to joseph and mary
male and female parents all of this is
an example
of the intentionality of god was in his
design
beautiful right so god has given us the
gift to create life i love this
principle
because this is where i think even as an
adult struggling with the identity issue
how do i explain this through our
ministry in a way that is biblical
and compassionate that goes against the
tide of what we're getting outside in
the world
is to talk about the fact that god gave
the gift
of creating life to one man and one
woman
in a in a committed relationship right
not only is that beautiful in itself but
it also is
the example of a creative god giving the
gift of creation
to man isn't that beautiful that's huge
and that's really profound and i think
that we
we miss that point sometimes especially
in light of identity and sexuality
so now we move a little bit uh we know
that satan was an angel
and that the angels were created above
human beings right we understand that
we also know that in isaiah 14 14 that
satan wanted to be like
god and so he wants the attributes of
god so imagine how angry he gets
when he realizes that god bypassed the
angels who were created
higher than the humans and he gave that
gift of creation
to human beings right so i don't know
about you but
you know i would naturally think hey you
skipped me to give it to them
so of course we know that satan wants to
steal kill
and to destroy what would he want to
steal kill and destroy more than
anything else
those attributes well not just to
reproduce
right but to kill that gift of
procreation and the
image of god that was given to us in the
opportunity to create that's life
two men sexually together does not
create life two women together do not
create life
uh the transgender issue destroys my uh
my my uh my genitals to the point where
i can't create life
all of this is a message from the enemy
to destroy that precious gift
of the image of god created in a
relationship between one man and one
woman
in the process of creating life even the
push of
abortion being a woman's right you know
every way that he can destroy life
and make it look glamorous or whatever
another application and
this is a really good point to jump in
here mike because um
unfortunately i've talked to other
nurses that work in a local area where
there's
a university an adventist university an
academy
and this nurse told me that the biggest
users of the abortion clinic
are the academy and the university the
adventist university so
it's a huge issue within even our
religion
where parents want to cover up the fact
that there's been either
molestation or sexual abuse within the
home or even by a boyfriend or something
and so to cover up one sin we commit
another sin to cover that up
again what message are you giving to
your children if life is so expendable
that you can get an abortion to cover up
some of these behaviors and i have
friends that are in their 50s now that
have raised children
but still live with the guilt and the
shame of the abortion that they had when
they were 16 or 15.
yeah so thank you it's a very good um
thing to bring out i'm glad you brought
that up i feel like if you try to cover
it up the truth won't fit
and god kind of addressed that in the
garden of eden after sin
adam and eve tried to cover themselves
up with fig leaves what did god do he
addressed it he removed that and he gave
them
uh his covering his coming but it was a
lamb's
lamb's covering yeah i wish you were my
mother you know what's so cool is that
you're seeing the application of these
principles and you're also seeing
the um it's not just enough to tell our
kids what the problem is
we have to also show them what the
solution is and we have to do that
through
a loving example of who god is rather
than a god that covers everything up
right that's very cool very excellent
thank you
this is this is even better than i
thought so everyone is unique on the
second day we want to talk about the
fact that everyone is unique we do a
little review
have the boys stand up then the girls
stand up talk about the review of
yesterday that god's image was
reproduced you know in each one of us
but that everyone is unique and that
every one of us has a fingerprint right
but did you know that each one of us not
only has a fingerprint
that we were individuals totally unique
from the other but only two kinds
male and female but that each one of us
has an internal fingerprint
that far beyond what you can see on the
outside is on the inside
my dna tells me right that i'm either a
male
or a female isn't that something and so
no matter what we do on the outside we
cannot disguise the fact
that our dna is just as much of a
fingerprint of who we are
either male or female and of course with
other uh
characteristics that makes us different
even from our brothers and sisters
so talking about that again doing a
little review about girls and boys
biology tells us who are
who we are dna is our internal
fingerprint it's unique and different
for everyone and there are two kinds of
dna
male and female so now we want to start
talking about something
that's very personal to me because when
i was in school and being called
queer
and all these words i want to
really stress to children that it's
important to acknowledge
these two kinds and how to identify as
those two kinds
and many times we have in our in our
mind that there's only one way to be a
guy and that's to be
a macho guy that you know is so macho
that nobody can ever attain to that that
level or whatever
right right very good very good example
but there are differences for male there
are some men that are macho men
like you yeah and then there's some men
that are gentlemen
romantic okay all right so this is
perfect so there are many ways to be a
boy we talk about there's some guys that
like sports
you know and then there's some guys that
like to play the piano or play
instruments or or more artistic
but that doesn't make them any less of a
boy that's right and i think it's
important to note also that the bible
says that our words
have the power of life and death that's
right and to affirm your students like
if you're a teacher
uh if you're a parent if you have a
child that's a bully or if you have a
child that's being bullied
i think it's important to to let your
children know
either way that if you're into the
sports or whatever that's okay
but if somebody else is into the piano
or the arts that's okay too
there are many ways to identify as a boy
i think as a
as a parent how you speak about you know
other kids like if you mention you know
this other kid did this or that
you have to be you have to be aware of
that your kid then
it can go into that same mode and
talk about other kids like that too and
so that's probably where a lot of the
bullying comes from
it's not organically just because that
kid sometimes it's the way the parents
were
treating that child or something or
speaking about other people and
and then all of a sudden that child
treats those other people and just the
way that those kids treat each other
can actually have a huge influence on
how that child turns out that's right
so to make sure that i'm understanding
you correctly are you saying that you
define
the difference between male and female
to children um
through biology not necessarily
personality well both
i think that they both have a beautiful
um
combination of who we are as individuals
talking about our uniqueness and
and you know what even on this panel uh
for the guys and then if there were more
girls
we could tell that there are distinct
differences even if you look at the four
of us here
you know they're you have different
likes you have different likes i do and
you do
but we're still all guys and that's the
beautiful thing i think about
christianity is that
it is inclusive you know and we
shouldn't be focusing on
um the things that make us different or
or push us
out of the group but rather my church
has been able to do that for me it's
like
they included me in their group even
though they didn't understand me or
necessarily relate to what i came from
but i was included by the men
and affirmed by the men as a man and
that in itself i think is one of the
principles that we should be telling our
children
where did children get that idea of
bullying i believe that it came from
whatever they're influenced by
primarily the parents then the other
things that they're exposed to
neighborhood kids or other influences
but i think a lot of times unfortunately
these
these um sexual norms come from our
parents thinking
oh you can't wear that pink shirt or you
know little girl you can't wear pants or
whatever that is
to to try to lock children into a
certain ideal of what masculinity
and femininity is so then with the girls
again talking about their different ways
to be identified as a girl you can be a
girly girl or a sporty girl
that's right you can climb trees you can
also be into sewing and cooking or the
arts
so again making sure that we even
play roll a little bit in what are the
things that you like to do and well
that's different than susie
and sherry likes to do this but susie
likes to do that but you're both
a girl and i think that these are really
great exercises you can do with children
to help them expand their understanding
that there are two kinds boys and girls
but
they're different ways to be boys and
different ways to be girls
so then we talk about dressing up now
did anyone not dress up as a child
anyway of course
i don't know i don't know but i used to
take t-shirts and put them over my head
and pretend that
that was long hair you know pretending
again to be the sex that i wanted to be
um but again that dressing up for a
child not understanding the difference
between fantasy and reality
role playing is a very healthy thing and
i believe that it's also
a blessing from god if it's channeled in
the right way
we don't want to force people and i love
this phrase somebody said
jesus didn't drive he draws and there
was a parent that called me
um a couple of years ago and he said my
son
is exhibiting a lot of feminine
characteristics is he gay and i said no
that doesn't make your son gay because
he's effeminate at four years old
he said but he did say to his mother a
couple of days ago he said
you know mom let's do this because we're
girls and he feared that his son was
identifying with the mom so
through a series of a couple of
questions and i asked him
ultimately i said well you know how much
time do you spend with your son
only child right and he said well
honestly and i and i was grateful for
the fact that he was so honest with me
said
i really don't like the personality of
my son and he said i find myself
just you know kind of letting him be and
so i come home and my son's in bed and
my wife is already taken care of him you
know throughout the day
and i leave a lot of times before he's
up and i said
the issue more than anything is the fact
that your son doesn't identify with you
because you're not available to him
and maybe your son also picks up on the
fact that you probably don't care for
his personality
so in his defense he's probably detached
from you but his mom is there and so he
identifies with her
so it's very normal for him to say hey
we're girls because you're the one i
identify with and you're the one that's
there for me and i said
if you want to make a difference in your
son's life i said
you have to start taking care of your
son you have to let him know that you're
invested you have to let him know that
you care
and you really have to address the fact
that you don't like your son's
personality
i said you have to be the one that's in
charge of his uh routine at the end of
the day
you have to help him out with bath time
you have to play with him intentionally
spend time with them
and i said and do the things that he
likes to do that doesn't compromise
that identity of masculinity but rather
draws him into that
now my dad you know saw that i had some
issues and my dad would take me out
shooting guns
you know but i was a really gentle
insecure sensitive child so
that freaked me out even more well and
then my dad took me out to
attack train german shepherds you know
police duty and so
it just it was just way too much he
overcompensated something that
that could have been very simple if we
just would have colored in my coloring
book with me
on the living room floor that would have
been huge to spend time
yeah and my mother overcompensated as
well when i was 10 years old my mother
could see i had gender
issues and so she gave me my father's
pornography magazines
you know thinking that that would help
me with sexual attraction to women but
instead it backfired because as i looked
at those images
on those pages i thought that if men
love these
women that if i look like those women
maybe men would love me too
the problem wasn't that i wanted to be a
girl the problem was that i didn't know
how to experience masculine love and
affirmation
in a way that was healthy and healing
makes sense so again
so i want to tell you the end of that
story so after six months
just six months the father called me on
the phone and said mike
he said i've been taking care of my son
i've been spending more time at home and
just last night my son
said to me dad let's hide from mom
because we're guys
so just a very simple exercise of
drawing him
into masculinity you know within a short
period of time really had a beneficial
effect
wow isn't that cool generally um
generally children when they're they're
younger
like probably about you know zero to
seven they do have a tendency to
latch more on the mom especially like
boys
and then from about 7 to 14
13 somewhere around there kind of
switches and then they
tend to fixate more on dad and then
after that it becomes
more balanced it's a little bit of both
so we've kind of seen that in all of
ours in the stages so i've got one who
just turned
you know eight and he's been more like
you know gotta spend time with dad
gotta go and go with dad and he's
outside and he's talking about
getting muddy and he's like and it was
so much fun you know
it's hilarious yeah that's cool yeah i
think as a parent too
i have a boy and a girl so um it's
important my wife and i actually
flip-flop
and we spend um individual time with
each one
just for the almost the opposite uh
reasons as well
like i want to spend time with my boy so
that he can really um you know bond and
and we can get close together too but i
also want to spend time with my girl
so that she can see like this is this is
the difference between a man and a woman
and this is how the man should treat the
woman and you know
so it's kind of a it's kind of something
that my wife and i have talked about for
for many years scotty that's so valuable
because even if your children aren't
necessarily
interested in that that specific parent
whether it's a same-sex parent or the
opposite sex parent
that is still crucial at those early
ages you can't wait until your son is
eight years old
for him to be interested in you you
still have to make that investment with
him and what i love about that
is that pubescent girls tend to
really start to learn how to flirt with
the father if he's safe and if he's in
the home
because that's how they're going to
learn to interact with the opposite sex
and the same thing you know a son's
heart during the puberty years
is more towards the mother because now
he's interested in the opposite sex and
he really wants to know how they click
and how they work
so all of that is just healthy maturing
but all of that begins at a very early
age and and i think that that's ideal
not only should you do things as a group
as a family but also
each individual child needs time from
both parents
the same sex parents and the opposite
sex parent as well
something that has come up is uh there
are
um there are children that are being
raised by by same-sex parents
and in particular there's a woman that
was raised by two
lesbian mothers and she said i had a
great childhood you know my parents
loved me both women loved her and she
grew up in school but
but it wasn't until she was married and
had children of her own
that she noticed the interaction of her
children with the father
that this light dawn on her that
children need
both sexes in their development she said
that when she saw
girls with their fathers at school she
she was jealous of them and that she
wanted to have a father because
she didn't understand how to relate to
that she also talked about how
she became sexually active at an early
age because she didn't have that
exposure to healthy masculinity and
and and somebody that she could identify
with so
and it's not a slam on the lgbt
community because let's be real
we know that in this world that's that's
very fallen and falling apart
that there are many parents that should
never have children whether they're
heterosexual or not and and i'm not here
to slam
same-sex parents but but i think that we
were designed and created again
if the image of god was placed in the
male and the female together
do you need both you need both for
healthy development so i have a question
so i've been putting you on the spot but
we're living in a very different time
now than ever before
so in a situation in a home where it's a
single parent whether it's a mom with a
son or a father with a daughter
and we're not able to socialize the way
we used to do you have any tips on
how to help the child have interaction
with both
or yes yes and and when when that
question does come up
in in our ministry after we present at
churches and stuff what about the fact
that we have more single mother
raising children now than ever before
and they're saying that now that the
pendulum has swung that way it can never
return
so how is it that that boys can have
healthy um
male role models and and you know what
the church can be a very scary place
we know that pedophiles are rampant in
in churches and in schools and so how
can you trust a man to be a male role
model for your sons
how can you find a male that would be
loving and kind and christian
to your daughters as well if you don't
have that example um
but i think that god is is incredibly
gracious and i think he hears the
prayers
of that single mother that's keeping two
or three jobs and yet has
um you know male and female children and
to ask god to show you to bring into
your life
you know an example of masculinity for
your sons because unfortunately now the
only examples that we have for
men about masculinity are rappers and
sports figures you know and
unfortunately that's not really a
christian example for our boys
and then our girls grow up thinking that
they're uh objects and that
you know that the only use that they
have is their ability to manipulate men
through
sexuality or sensuality and again you
know we have kids that are experiencing
sex much earlier
i believe because of the absence of the
father figure in the home
or even dual parents so it's a new
challenge for the church
and and for people in leadership in the
church that are listening to this i
believe that not only should our sabbath
schools be
um directed towards identifying
uh sexuality and identity in our young
children in our early sabbath school
classes but
wouldn't that be an excellent ministry
to really
address the single mothers that are
raising children or single parents that
have children
and wouldn't that be a great ministry to
reach out and to help support those
children
and get them involved so that they you
know have healthy examples of
what real masculinity and femininity is
so what i'm hearing is you still
need kind of that time with a male
figure or a female figure depending on
which
single parent raised you may be yes you
still have to have that
interaction yes but i i dare that came
to my mind if that isn't
the case if that's hard to achieve is to
just keep that line of distinction very
clear
so going back to the story that you
shared with the mom and her son
and there was that attachment there and
he said quick let's hide from dad
because we're girls
for her to have said maybe actually no
i'm i'm a woman and you're my little
prince my my little boy
but yes let's go hide from daddy you
know just to keep that
communication and be straight with him
in that way but apparently that was
missing because the mother didn't know
what to say
you know and so she didn't know how to
affirm that but she didn't probably
didn't want to ostracize the child to
eat even more
because she probably was sensing the
lack of interest from the father too
okay who knows who knows there's a
myriad of reasons why and
we don't really know exactly what she
did say but this is
something that's really interesting even
in studies they've shown that even if a
child came from my background that
defensively detached from the father
even if i had an identical twin brother
that he may have grown up with
perfectly heterosexual attractions while
i grew up with homosexual attractions
and so some characters can survive in a
single-family home
even if they didn't have a same-sex
parent however they have shown
that there is definitely um an effect
when you have single parent homes and
when you have lack of that
all right so so let's just address that
maybe for a moment that
even if you swing to the other side and
you're perfectly heterosexual
but you're having sex with every um girl
that you see
that's not healthy either right and
sometimes
you know guys that grow up thinking that
they've been surrounded by femininity
then they think that they have to have
sex with multiple girls to prove that
they're a man whatever that is
all of that comes from again the fact
that they didn't have
a healthy understanding of christian
masculinity
and femininity right so as a church what
i'm hearing is
is really the need to have more
ministries targeting
those maybe church members that are part
of single families and
creating activities or events that you
know the church could actually step in
and fulfill that role is that what i'm
hearing
yes but there would have to be some type
of a vetting process to make sure that
we're not
setting kids up to be abused or you know
yeah
that's difficult because that's a
difficult situation for a church to be
in
yeah i mean but it's definitely a
ministry that i believe that sometimes
churches are able to do that
maybe maybe um maybe an elder in the
church or a deacon in the church
steps up and sees a situation and maybe
you know one sunday a month what he does
is he takes the kids out for ice cream
or
you know he goes over to the house and
you know fixes the cupboards that are
loose
or you know checks the air in the tires
for the single mom
that in itself is a ministry but it goes
much further because then
that little boy living in that home says
whoa you know he's not my dad but he
comes over
and he helps my mom and so you know you
start to learn the principles of
christianity of helping people out
or maybe even another family can adopt a
family wouldn't that be something
you're an intact family so you and your
wife and your two kids go to another
family that's a single family
and just bring them to your home every
friday night for vespers show them what
worship time looks like
you know taking the taking the boys
aside your son and maybe the son of this
woman
and saying hey we're going to go fishing
or whatever that is there are so many
different ways that we can do that in a
healthy environment
but it definitely is a ministry that i
think is lacking in our church
wonderful good advice cool all right so
let's go on this
you guys are giving me so many more
ideas this thing's going to blow up so
so we all like to play dress up and and
you know it's just a big part i think of
development to
you know look at this image you see a
kid being kind of like a bookkeeper
another one a baker and
um anyway there's all different kinds of
ways that you can dress up and kids love
to dress up
but at the end of the day talking to the
kids what do we do with our costumes
well we take them off and we put them
away right so maybe during the day i can
be a cowboy but then at night i take off
my cowboy hat and my stirrups or
whatever
and i'm just a regular boy again all of
this is healthy
right i uh funny story is my um my
nephew saw the box cover of
of um who samson samson and goliath
and samson is wearing like all these
muscles and he's holding up this big
rock and he's got this strange look on
his face like ah
like this well my nephew couldn't tell
the difference between a smile and a
strain
and so my nephew had this muscle t this
muscle
shirt that was flesh-colored but it had
muscles built into it
and my sister said she couldn't get it
off of him and every day
he would walk around the house carrying
the sofa cushion over his head
smiling because he was
imitating you know what he was seeing
and he was dressing up as that a
beautiful story so i talk about it's fun
to pretend
it disguises who we are and then i asked
the kid but does it change who you are
and of course children they're very
elementary and very simplistic and we
all know
no it doesn't change who i am but you
know it does disguise who i
am and then i go it gives us the
appearance of something or someone else
sometimes our disguises really fool
people
so then i segue into genesis chapter 27
and i talk about the story of jacob and
i asked him what does the name
jacob mean which i love thank you
isn't that amazing that the bible kind
of explains itself so jacob is a
deceiver
and what did he do is he deceived his
father so he got his brother's
birthright lived up to his name
yeah and you know what how beautiful you
know in sabbath school in your family
worship or whatever
really expound on this the fact that he
put the animal
skins on his arm so he'd be hairy like
his brother right
and how he disguised himself and he did
he used his disguise
in a very negative way in a very
deceptive way is that right
so disguises can be used in a play and
funful way but it can also be used
in a very negative way that deceives
people that's right so um
again then going about how we dress also
tells people who we are
it's a costume right it's something that
we wear and so i go to deuteronomy
chapter 22 and verse five and this is a
very difficult
verse to really unpack but if you've
established those principles in your
children
the differences between boys and girls
and and
those are issues that we could really
pontificate about about
girls wearing pants and boys wearing
pink or whatever and i have some
you know definite opinions about that
but that's not why we're having this
discussion but if you're affirming your
children
into their identity of male or female
when you get to this verse this is
probably a verse that will probably get
deeper as your children get older it
says that a woman shall not wear that
which pertains unto a man
neither shall a man put on a woman's
garment for all that do so
are an abomination unto the lord thy god
as a person who was transgender for 20
years i was transgender until 20 years
thinking that i had to have a sex change
for even god to accept me this
is a very difficult verse for people
that struggle with what i struggle with
because
my first inclination is to think that
i'm an abomination to god
but when you look at this verse god does
not condemn
those that have those feelings he
condemns the behavior
which i think is real important as as if
we want to share the compassion of god
he understands that there are people
that have that feeling
he says just don't do it because what
that does is that destroys this gift
that i gave you
you know your fingerprint from the
inside as well as the outside through my
genitals that
that's what tells me who i am right and
so again
i shouldn't have to show you my genitals
for you to know that i'm male
so i think that god put this out there
saying just wear clothes that helps to
identify which side you're on
right that's a good logic cool right
right and then first corinthians chapter
14 and verse 33 it says for god is
i'm not the author of confusion but of
peace
and again this is we're just at the end
of the second day oh wow this is so cool
you guys
so again the third day and then i start
bringing it into the flood and
and it had to be the holy spirit that
started bringing me this because i'm not
that crazy about the story myself and i
think that the rainbow is overrated
i honestly i see the rainbow and it just
kind of like oh yeah again but
there's a really powerful opportunity
here
and and what came into my mind and i was
thinking about um
as it was in the days of noah so shall
it be at the end of time
doesn't that mean that we should really
know the story of noah even more
as we're living in this time so why did
god have noah build an ark and the kid
said because you know the world was bad
and
everything had to be destroyed and i'm
amazed that little kids you know
know the story and that's because they
go to church every week so how many did
god call into the art you know
two two of every animal and i go wow
that's great so
uh again genesis 6 19 says and
every living thing of all flesh two of
every sort shall thou bring into the ark
to keep them alive with thee and they
shall be
male and female and i said so you know
did god bring two boys of you know every
kind no
was it two girls of every guy no a boy
and a girl and i go well why why would
god have to bring a boy in a girl
so they can have babies honestly
we have complicated this issue so much
when children actually know
so if you establish the foundation in
them and you teach them these principles
then when the artificial or the or the
um
the manufacturer comes up you know about
identity and sexuality
your children are already foundationally
understanding
that no it's a boy and a girl that makes
children it was a boy and girl that it
takes to create the image of god
it was a gift of god through the
relationship of a mother and a father
not two mothers not two fathers that
created life
you implant those principles and then
when they're exposed to the other
they'll be able to sort out or at least
know
that the foundation was god's way right
because the reality is they're going to
get that
wrong picture at some point i i don't
know about you guys but i remember when
other kids at school would talk to us
about this and
it was like so scotty i want to know how
old were you when that started man i
think i i think i was probably in
five five years yeah so i was in public
school around a lot of
neighbors and stuff too so so mike what
age for you because
for me it was much later you mean when i
got exposed to homosexuality or what
the whole idea of just sexuality or
anything like yeah just
inappropriate i feel like i don't
remember a time that i didn't know
yeah but so that's even more frightening
than my
expectation but i was i was probably
like
six or something when i found out what
homosexual was
okay because of a friend of my parents
in the army
and actually he hung out at our house a
lot and these neighborhood kids would be
like
your friend's gay or whatever i was like
no he's not what does that even
but that's a perfect example of why if
we're having conversations with our
parents
you could come home and say daddy what
is a homosexual
and and you can do it in a biblical way
that is loving
kind that doesn't reject your uncle or
this person
but instead recognizing that we live in
a world that is diverse
that has you know that that has strayed
away from god's ideal
as we've affirmed what god's ideal is to
them i think it's so interesting you
brought the
days of noah and the rainbow because i'm
like as in the days of noah and we keep
seeing this rainbow you know it's like
god's promise was this rainbow and
satan's like no
i'm gonna fly that rainbow again i mean
we we could do an entire
just talk just on this rainbow i mean
that that that isn't an
an interesting thing that that god was
basically saying list
because of the wickedness on the earth i
will not destroy it again
and it's almost like now it's used as
the symbol of like oh yeah
i'm going to do whatever i want to and
you're not going to
know something the lgbt rainbow is not a
bad thing
their premise is that the rainbow covers
everybody and that everybody should be
treated
fairly and with love so that ideal is
correct but it's still a deviation from
what god's intention about the rainbow
is so we're not quite there yet you're
kind of bringing up something that i
kind of want to ultimately get to
uh in patriarchs and prophets it talks
about the beasts of every description
the fiercest
as well as the most gentle we're seeing
coming from mountain and forest
and quietly making their way toward the
ark this is what really grabbed me
animals obeyed the command of god
guided by holy angels they went in two
and two unto noah
into the ark noah didn't even gather
those animals they just came to him
and if i was living in the antediluvian
world and i saw
animals two by two coming from the
mountains of all kinds going to the ark
something's going to happen you know
something's up something's up and you
know what i believe that because we're
not talking about this
we are not a testimony to the world
about what's coming what's soon to break
upon our world
but even this it says that the animals
came male and female it wasn't that
noah's decision
noah didn't get to decide who he was
going to take or what god himself
brought
them to the ark that noah created and so
then i talk to the kids and i say
all right so who got on the ark and they
go noah and and his sons and i go was
that all
no their wives go why did he need their
wives so they could make babies
they understand this right we're the
ones that complicate it for them
and it was just a beautiful expression
of that and then how did god preserve
the animals to continue
uh to have life after the flood and
again
using these images you know show your
children in nature
god's plan you know you want to teach
your children about identity and
sexuality
take them to a farm you know if your
kids are in the city or whatever they
need
they need a field trip to the farm to
show it takes a male and a female like
you know the difference is between
a chicken and a rooster and it takes one
of each to make an egg or a chick
you know uh in the lion kingdom you know
the male lion looks totally different
than the female lion
and yet it takes both of them to create
this this life or this cub
i believe that because of science
because we've got in vitro fertilization
we can
you know take a a sperm and and
fertilize
the egg and put it in anybody that we
want and you can create
whatever you want and so in essence we
kind of made ourselves to be like god
but really you cannot create life
without a male sperm
and a female egg no matter who you put
it inside of or who you say their
parents are
and again bringing this back down to the
basics i think is really beneficial for
children to understand that
growing up now this is really
interesting because
um in today's world we see
um this very thing uh
being countered i guess
you know you start to see scientists are
like
i've never heard of this talk of before
this time
but like yeah there's this certain class
of dolphin
or or seahorse or whatever and
and they you know they have a male male
relationship or a
female female relationship and it's like
they're it's almost like
reaching or grasping i mean maybe
there's
something that changes along the way i
don't know
but it's it's certainly not the rule
you know if it is if it it's this
biological anomaly it's certainly not
the rule and it's like
you 20 years ago 10 years ago
you never heard that you know it was
like oh now we need that example because
we're
trying to propagate this information
like where was that before if it was so
important
you know i i have heard about the
seahorse thing but i like
this comedian jim gaffigan he said
you know that was just some stubborn
scientist he's like oh that's
that's the male seahorse like he's
having babies
the male has the babies all right like i
mean
you should just say oh it has the babies
that must be the female but some silver
scientist
no male has the baby well i i like that
you brought that up
um keith because i think it's real
important that
um the children understand that and you
can use the bible to really help to
explain that
when when god created the earth he put
adam in charge of the animals
and we know that 6 000 years of
degeneration
have not only had their effect on humans
but also on the animal kingdom
so i've also um been asked that question
and my response is
i don't take my examples from the animal
kingdom as to how i'm to live
you know god put man in charge of the
animal kingdom however
through sin and through you know we have
lions that kill animals and eat them
because we know that in heaven that'll
never happen
so sin has affected not only humans but
also the animal kingdom so whatever
i think is a bad scientific experiment
if you're taking one example
out of the millions that are this way
and you're saying because of the one now
that's
that's the rule whereas like you know
the majority of
of the animal kingdom operates
underneath this
you know male female has a baby some
species are asexual i can't breed
myself yeah so you can't really make
make the rule
out of the you know sort of minou
minor changes that we can't explain
right
so another point that i want to make
about that is that in the animal kingdom
they do not have the frontal lobe that
we have and
in the animal kingdom uh the act of
procreation for them
isn't an expression of love and it's an
expression of self-preservation
and also on genetics or whatever but
when it comes to human beings god was
very specific that he gave us much more
than just
procreation to keep the world alive he
did it as an expression to know
the image of god expressed in a
relationship between
one man and one woman he's the one that
was the
the maker of us and he also knows what's
best for us but we're different than the
animal kingdom
we have more emotions and and um
and what's the word for it not just
emotions but uh
spirituality as a matter of fact let's
talk about that for a second
sex is an act of worship you know and
that's going to freak everybody out
that's watching
but sex is an act of worship because you
know in the relationship between one man
and one woman
sexually this is god's ideal and
designed
to bring the image of god in that
creative
act right the bible says whatsoever what
is it what do you
eat what you drink whatever you do to
alter the glory of god okay
but but let's take it just a little bit
further because even in satanic rituals
that there's all kinds of sexuality
being expressed there whether it's
bestiality or homosexuality or
necrophilia or pedophilia or whatever it
is anything that's sexual outside of
god's design
is there to create an environment of
worship
isn't that interesting and i never
thought of it really to that extent
before
but anything whether it's pornography
masturbation pre-marital sex
whatever that is all of that is an act
of worshiping
either god or the enemy for yourself
yeah yeah i never expected to bring that
up today but so again on day four here
we are day four and
remember parents some of this stuff you
don't want to share with your
four-year-old but
i think it's important that as you watch
this program
that it should help you to start having
those conversations with your children
no matter what age they are
and it should start at the earliest age
that they can understand whatever they
can
i think this is amazing what you've
shared so far i wish would be done at
every school this is neat who knows
maybe even the adults will learn
something
well i mean what age are we talking
about the age of appropriateness to
bring things up like are we talking four
five six all right how about it how
about let me give you an instance um
a parent has a little boy and the little
boy comes out of the shower
you know and he's he's just been bathed
or whatever and all of a sudden he
starts pulling on his genitals
and of course you know it's not um it's
not a moral
issue or whatever but it can certainly
lead to that early on so a parent
sits your little boy aside and just
confirms the fact you know
jesus gave you your fingers and jesus
gave your nose and your ears but he also
gave you that
and he also asked that you not play with
that or whatever that's something
special in private or whatever
and the little kid like learns okay well
i don't pull on that
and you know you put your kid in his
pajamas or whatever but
teaching your children at the earliest
of ages what god's principles are
and not in a way to shame them but to
help redirect them
into healthy sexuality and identity and
then when that child was a little bit
older when he got to be eight years old
the mother and the father sat the child
down and started to talk about
hormones and how they're going to be
surging and usually at the age of 10 you
start having these changes in your body
so before it happened they didn't just
wait for their child to go through
puberty
and then talk about masturbation and
pornography they warned him ahead of
time when they felt that he was ready
to receive that information it breaks my
heart when
uh when we go to uh different churches
or schools and and parents
actually um refuse to allow their
children to be in our programs
because they want to protect their
innocence and unfortunately
um no matter how old we are or whatever
as our ages have gotten younger and
younger you've been exposed more and
more to sexual things
and unfortunately through the web and
through neighbors and through kids
experimenting
and kids having access to pornography
they start imitating what they watch
on their father's or mother's
pornography or on their own devices
and we have children that are as young
as four and five
you know imitating sexual acts that
they've seen and heard you know
when i didn't even think of sexual
thoughts until i was 13 years old
does it hold true that if they don't
know they won't do
not not true at all and you know there's
some people like that woman
you know she said i don't know why i was
obsessed with seeing a naked man as a
little girl
you know she doesn't know what um put
that in her heart or mine she doesn't
remember ever being molested or abused
but if that does happen we as parents
should not be
disgusted or or um shocked but instead
use it as an opportunity to guide their
little minds and their little hearts
into the way that would be biblical and
loving the way that i remember as
a young child being exposed to sexuality
was
we were actually a family that had a
boat and
went to a lake and went waterskiing a
lot and we went and we took
our dog one time who was only a single
dog at our house
and he was a male dog and so um right
in front of us as a little kid i
remember he had gotten a hold of a
female dog
and you know did what dogs would want to
do
and as a child i mean i was like what
are they doing
and my mom said the entire ride home i
was just like
question question question question like
does it hurt why are they yelling
like i wouldn't leave it alone and so my
parents at that point
had to you know talk about it but but it
was because
i'd seen this thing in nature and then
now it was like
oh well what else does that you know
right that's right and that's basically
how i got my education um from early on
that was organic
you know that's the way that life
happens and you know you got to be ready
for that at any time you know you don't
expect that your dog's going to
you know find a female dog when you go
on a family outing even if it's a
sabbath afternoon
but when it happens again i just keep
taking my example from that mother that
she she saw the situation and she used
it as an opportunity
to not affirm not only affirm what
they're seeing but also to make it
um spiritual and a biblical application
of identity
and sexuality does that folks are good
no that's it okay there's a text and
there's a first peter always be willing
and
ready and willing to give an answer to
what you believe but i think for parents
always just expect that right yeah to
give an answer about whatever might fly
out your kids mouth but
i remember as a as a kid there was a
saying like if you don't understand it
talking about sex then you shouldn't be
engaging in it
and if you can't explain something then
you really don't understand it so
hopefully having that understanding of
what
you as a parent are engaging in and
being able to talk about it in the
simplest way will help you
approach it with your kids yeah yeah and
some of the really valuable
conversations that i think go along with
that is also
um about you know when you wear your
clothing you know
what does physical touch look like
between boys and girls and
and to establish those boundaries
because i see those boundaries
even less defined on in kids that are in
academy
it was it was not uncommon to see a girl
with her head in the lap of another girl
and they were friends and
the girl might be stroking her hair but
now i'm seeing it in behavior with the
guys in the guy's dorm
which is brand new but now that we have
these
these boundaries being broken down about
sexuality and identity
you have guys that are experimenting now
with with things that are
are stimulating and that's what they do
and we're seeing behaviors that
that i think are invading the personal
space of what christians should engage
in
naturally anyway so again teaching your
children at the same age that
you know you don't ever touch anyone
where your clothes are covered and
you know what's appropriate clothing
what's appropriate touch and if somebody
is coming towards your child you should
teach them run to mommy you know run to
daddy you know
because i hear so many stories of
children that have been abused
that felt that they were bad and they
were afraid to come to their mother and
father
so they endured the abuse for years
thinking that their parents would you
know uh
yeah you always want to make it a safe
space for your children to come and
chat with you absolutely so again then
talking about
the farm life and and what it means to
you know go to the farm
show your kids you know if fortunately
for you it came for you you know
your dog and this female dog gave you an
example right there but if you don't
have that opportunity you live in the
city
take your kids to the country you know
when they're two and three or five or
seven or
all along that age to remind them about
god's intentionality about identity and
sexuality yeah
don't start looking at stuff on youtube
no no no
yeah absolutely so i i want to talk
about the rainbow and i think that this
is um a very pivotal part and i and it
i think it's going to get a lot more
personal you know for all of us
when we start talking about that because
we have something that was given to us
by god and i think
that um that even in its most innocent
way it's been
deceived and been misunderstood but i
think that it's also important kids love
color they relate to color
and and unfortunately i was somewhere in
europe and i was giving this
presentation
and we went down in the basement and i
looked in the cradle world room
and don't you know they had a rainbow
but it didn't have enough colors
and so it's not sad that you know even
in the sabbath school room we could be
giving the wrong
impression of what god's ideal is so
what do you mean by that
what do you mean that there weren't
enough colors let's talk about that all
right so what does the rainbow represent
and we talked to the kids
and um go to genesis chapter 9 and verse
13 and 15 talking about the rainbow
after the flood i i set my bow in the
cloud and there it shall be for a token
of a covenant that's interesting i
didn't even realize this until i found
this verse
it's a covenant and a covenant is an
agreement between two parties
i'm not dragged into this agreement i
have to be willing to decide that yes
i'm in this covenant but it's also
god is the other one in this covenant
relationship
and he says and it shall come to pass
that when i bring a cloud over the earth
that the bow shall be seen in the cloud
and i will remember my covenant which is
between me and you
and every leaving creature of all flesh
and the waters shall no more become a
flood to destroy all flesh
so it's a covenant the rainbow is a
coven an agreement
and what jesus says if you love me keep
your commandments right
and i think god did this because you
think about
man's natural reaction is just going to
be out of fear like you know oh my god
god's going to just destroy us yeah if
we don't do what he says i got that
image as a kid yeah and this is god
saying like hey listen
like like i started over fresh but i
will not do this again
you know and that way we can still
choose to obey him you know not just out
of a
sake of fear but just you know scotty i
love that you bring that up because
i want to segue at the end of this
presentation
to really exemplify the love of god
because i think a lot of kids
like myself think of god as kind of a
scary individual and if you don't do it
my way you're dead
and and i think that a lot of parents
put that in their kids sometimes
with these ideas about identity and
sexuality
in a way that they think is going to
protect their kids but also in another
way
may actually be doing more work for the
enemy by
making god appear as someone who's
judgmental and critical and rejecting
if if god was like just really
angry and and wanted to take care of the
situation
he wouldn't have waited 120 years
you know right oh that's a good point so
so you want to kill that
yeah because he he built in this space
of time of 120 years you know
noah is preaching and laboring and
they're seeing the ark
go up and you know by the time you get
to the animals it's like
this is this is way towards the end of
this thing
so you know if god wanted to obviously
he could have just been like yeah we're
done
you know flood time yeah but he didn't
do that and
and i don't know if it really
took noah like i mean did it take him
120 years to build the ark
or you know i mean that seems like a
long time to build something like that
maybe it did maybe he was just kind of
pacing himself slowly slowly maybe he
was part of the union i don't know yeah
i don't know but you know he would cure
yeah right right in either case god gave
humanity a long time to
turn and and that arc was open for
anybody who wanted to get on
those those are the same principles that
you should be sharing with your children
as well those are
beautiful ideas to to start showing your
children that god was patient
he wanted to make sure that everybody
could get on the boat that wanted on the
boat
120 years wow a kid can't even fathom a
year let alone 120.
yeah but those principles are perfect i
think for every parent
sharing with their children to
understand
all right so i bring up the rainbow and
the rainbow has seven colors
and for somebody in the gay culture for
over 20 years
you know the rainbow to me was kind of
tired and um
anyway as a christian recognizing that
god
uses the number seven in a lot of really
profound ways
and um as a christian coming in i
thought that i had to be perfect and
that was the image that i got as a young
person
also is that i had to be perfect for god
to love me and seven
means perfection and most people agree
with that statement
but it wasn't until i really started to
understand the application of the number
seven
the seven means completion and it means
the completion to the process of
perfection
why couldn't somebody just share that
with me and that i didn't realize that
even my own journey
out of the gay culture out of
transgenderism out of sexual addiction
out of pornography addiction it has an
application for every single person
in the universe that the number seven is
the process
of perfection it took seven times for
the for the uh
uh for the captain to dip into the river
before he was healed of leprosy
seven times mary magdalene was healed of
demons before
she was clean of those demons so it was
a process
and understanding that is really
beautiful so if seven
represents god's rainbow seven is a
beautiful way to start implementing that
principle to your children like
let's count sevens you know like seven
what you know seven this and there's
stories of seven that are in the bible
showing your children that sin comes
with the human condition
but that the process of perfection is
the work of sanctification isn't that
right
and that god is going to see you through
and so you may have been really lousy
today as a kid you know we had a really
bad day but tomorrow we're going to
start it all over
and god is going to help us to get to
that that process of perfection
that's a principle that really applies
to me even today at 60 years old
and i could have used that at 3 or 4 or
7 or 10 or whatever
you know anywhere along that way and the
rainbow is a beautiful way put a rainbow
in your kid's room but make sure it has
seven colors
because that's god's rainbow and what
was what does the number six represent
man oh where do you get that
because on the sixth day man was created
right and we know that the even the
number 666 is the number of a man
so six represents something from man
man's men's thinking or men's creation
right
and so anything other than seven colors
in the rainbow
is not god's rainbow pure and simple and
i think what's really beautiful is you
can focus
on god's way and you don't even have to
address in a negative way
any other rainbow that's out there any
other rainbow that doesn't have all the
colors
and and god's rainbow is specific it has
seven
distinct colors and in a distinct order
did you know that
so if you see the rainbow out of sync
it's not from god either
and this is an example of that and it
took me a while to find out but
it's red orange yellow green
uh blue thank you and then uh
indigo and then violet that's right
that's right and it happens in
in that form and i'm doing a study on
the rainbow so you know what the colors
actually
represent oh stop that that's another
one that's another one because
i have another bible study that i do
where we discover the colors of the
bible
the colors of the rainbow through the
bible wow
like what they mean it really is it
really is
it's super cool all right so i don't
want to digress but so the one that's
missing
is the indigo one mm-hmm and then flag
which is a combination
of um purple and blue yes purple and
blue thank you
all right so so again talking to the
kids what does the rainbow how does a
rainbow talk about god's love
in genesis chapter 9 and verse 11 it
talks uh it's a covenant between you and
me we talked about that
uh the rainbow is to remind us of a
promise who does the rainbow cover
it covers everybody and i think that
this is a really important point
because when we have children you don't
want to go to a store and all of a
sudden your kids see
a gay couple wearing a rainbow flag and
your kid coming up and saying
that's not from god and you're going to
go to hell and blah blah blah
we need to also let them know that the
rainbow covers
everybody and that even if people aren't
following god's principles on identity
sexuality
or the rainbow or whatever it's not an
opportunity to criticize them
or to set them straight as much as it is
to have compassion
to recognize that they don't have the
understanding that we have
let's pray for them right let's work for
them and
because too many times i think that we
instill those principles that
if they don't believe the way we do
they're lost we're saved
they're bad we're good and when you
start instilling that in children
i think that that leads us to some of
the attitudes that we have in
christianity now
of this condescension about the the
sinner and the saint
when when really we're all in this boat
together right the art
so again uh who does the rainbow covered
so revelation chapter 10 and verse one
uh the rainbow that's over um when jesus
comes to take us home
and i saw another mighty angel come down
from heaven clothed with a cloud
and a rainbow was upon his head and his
face was
as it were the sun and his feet as
pillars of fire
so when this this artificial jesus comes
and shows himself
it's quite possible that there's going
to be a rainbow around it right yeah
how many colors do we want to make sure
that rainbow has right
okay and then revelation chapter four
and verse three
and he that sat was to look upon like a
jasper and a sardine stone
and um there was a rainbow round about
the throne in sight like unto an
emerald so again teaching your children
the beautiful things the principles of
the rainbow i think are really important
especially in this day and time to make
sure that they understand
the true rainbow and anything else that
might be man's invention and it's so
funny you can get so deep with the truth
no time to study the counterfeit
right right so again how much does god
love me this is the final day and this
guy's is the most important
day but you cannot have this day unless
you've done the foundational work of
laying
about identity sexual all of that was
done
in an expression of god's love not
because it was a bunch of rules that he
gave us to arbitrarily follow because
he's god
and he can do whatever he wants it's
because this was a gift and this
this story came to me profoundly through
marissa's story
because it was through reading psalms
139 that she discovered
that it was god's pursuit of her that
brought her to an
understanding that her gift of being
female was really just that that it was
a gift from god
so again talking about in jeremiah
chapter one and verse five before i
formed you in the belly i knew you
and before you came forth out of the
womb that really expresses that you know
god has an intimate relationship even
from the very onset he's knit us
together
yeah you know any any and he has a
relationship with us
you know from that perspective amen amen
i totally agree
so starting with psalms 139 and psalms
139 is really the
the whole chapter that encompasses to me
identity sexuality
and everything from god's hand but first
in verse 5 it talks about how you have
protected me in front and behind
you have laid your hand upon me now
verse 10 it says your hand will lead me
and your right hand
will hold me in verse 17 it says your
thoughts towards me are precious oh god
your good thoughts about me are too many
that i can't even count them
when you start telling your kids these
verses
you are leading them up to such an
affirmation
of an expression of love that came from
god's hand it's not that he just made
you male in you and female and you've
got to just suck it up and deal with it
instead it was something that god wanted
to bless you with
and in his pursuit of you it's like you
know what kenny you're the one
that really needs to be a female because
god has a special work a
special plan for you and this is how he
saw you and it wasn't given to you
as a work or a condemnation or a joke it
was given to you as a special
gift because of his love right and so
that in itself also helps people to deal
with
when we have confusion and you know what
there are people that are confused about
their identity
of which i was one and and it's
reasonable to
to know that even in a christian school
they're going to be children who are
going to
be confused about their gender identity
or about their sexuality
so we have to be sensitive about that
and i think that if we use this in a
correct way
if we use this loving approach if the
children see that you're loving too
and that you are not biased then they'll
be able to come forward and say
i am confused sometimes too or i feel
like i'm a girl trapped in a boy's body
or i feel like i have attractions to the
boys in school you know when i'm in gym
class or whatever
and when you have that coming out in a
family situation
then imagine what you can help to
protect your children from
when they hear it on the outside and
then imagine the parents that aren't
surprised when they start to realize
that their children have
gender identity disorders or sexuality
you know
confusion because they came to you first
right it wasn't a surprise it wasn't a a
big mystery because they trusted you
enough to come to you and let you know
what they're struggling with now we have
this movement in the church that is
basically saying that
it's okay to be gay and that that's how
god made you so
wouldn't it be awful if we as parents
lost that precious opportunity
to affirm what god's ideal was for our
children and help guide them
biblically spiritually mentally and if
we
and if we misguide our children into
thinking that it's not an
issue or it's not a problem with god
you've not helped your children
you've created a bigger problem for your
children right and not only
are they in a situation where they could
be
no other word that i can think of you
know lost but then what about the
responsibility for the parents when we
get before god and god says
what did you do with those children that
i gave you that's right right
and let's be real it's hard to not be
biased we all have our own perspectives
our own life experiences
i think that's the place the role of the
holy spirit right there to have that
connection with god personally before
you try to
reach out to other people even your kids
amen
there was a situation i sat down with um
a young man and his mother and
we were at lunch and this young man had
um
had gone through the gay culture and
struggled with
same-sex attraction and he was
biblically with the understanding
that that god was going to heal that and
god was going to give him the victory
over that
and he was living according to that and
then
through his own um you know his own
walk and his mother supported him and
his mother was right there behind him
and so uh they picked me up and we went
to lunch and as we were talking i
started to realize that
that my friend's understanding had
changed his position had shifted
and that he was now affirming same-sex
you know monogamous relationships
and so after he was explaining to me his
position and i made sure to be
extremely compassionate because of
course he knew my position and now i'm
the
opposition right and i looked at his
mother and i said
so how does that affect you like where
you know
what's your response from the news from
your son
and basically she just threw it all out
and she said well i trust my son and
whatever he decides is fine with me
and that broke my heart because now
the mother was you're in a position or a
role to basically kind of add
you know well you know this is maybe how
god intended to be
or or give a little guidance right there
and you affirmed that action right so
now you're assisting your son
in his deception and what about the
eternal consequences of that decision
right and let's not let's not be
insensitive to the fact that there are
parents out there
and you know what i talk to them all the
time and on our prayer line
you know we have situations with parents
that are like you know
my son won't talk to me or my daughter
won't talk to me until
i accept their lgbt life and
you know i love them i i want to have
meaningful conversations with them but
now they refuse to come to my house
they refuse to bring their children to
me you know it creates
a big um resistance in these families if
we hold on to the truth
but if we give in and allow them these
ideas
and directions against what we believe
that the bible says
then in essence we're really just as
much a part of their
their future eternal destiny i think it
goes
back to the communication from when
those children were young
because back to the garden of eden it's
not good for men to be alone well it's
not good for anyone to be alone in that
isolation that's probably where the
child
just couldn't really grapple with these
different ideas and went down the wrong
path or whichever path they chose it was
in that isolation so as they're growing
to continue to isolate themselves from
their community from their support
system
i mean good point candy because um i
think that that needs to be addressed as
well because a lot of parents experience
extreme guilt you know maybe you weren't
a christian when you had your children
maybe you were converted when you were
you know in your 30s and your children
were in their early teens
that's really difficult to start
implementing those principles now when
maybe you were
lgbt affirming and you know whatever
that was
but here's the thing that i really want
to be clear on because regardless of
what you you gave to your children or
what you weren't able to give to your
children
god still makes up the difference that's
right and and that doesn't mean that we
throw out the truth so that we're loving
and still connected to our children
by affirming the truth you're giving
your children something to come back to
remember it says raise up your children
in the way they should go
in the way that they should go and when
they are old they will not depart from
it and somebody said this to me and i
thought it was so wise they said
if you don't lay out the foundation for
your children
they'll have nothing to come back to
wow isn't that something that can't come
back to what you don't have
yeah that's a deep thought right there
right so i want to pull you back to this
because all of this i think is
culminating for exactly the point that
we want to make and
and your your perspectives have really
helped me
to really solidify exactly what i
believe
this is so um profoundly supporting but
psalms 139 and verse 16 your eyes saw my
form
and being incomplete all my members are
in your book
which you made when before there was
nothing
and then verse 23 says search inside my
heart dear god
look inside me and know my thoughts
and you know for the child who struggles
with same-sex attraction the child that
struggles with
gender dysphoria you know this is a very
real verse and when you unpack this with
your children
listen you know to let your child know
that you know what there's a lot of
things in me that god is still working
on
and when a parent can apologize for
their children and say i did this wrong
i want to do this right
all of that is teaching your children
that hey it's okay
i can share the fact that i'm that i
made a mistake or that i messed up
you know and that god wants to help me
you're teaching your children through
your own example
through your own repentance and
reformation how your children can do it
and when you have a relationship with
jesus christ more than what you say
is how you live that saying you know
what daddy messed up again
and i shouldn't have said that to you
can you ever forgive me and let's pray
to god
and you know you're teaching your
children how to have a relationship
with jesus christ i didn't get that you
know i i grew up in a family where you
had to do the things that were right and
you know dad never apologized for
anything and dad was perfect and
yet i could see his humanity and that
was far from perfect
so when 19 years old or 20 years old
when i walked away from the church it
was basically because
i didn't have an example of somebody
having a relationship with jesus christ
it was either you serve me and bow down
and obey me or you're lost
forever and so i thought okay well i
can't keep your law
so i'm out of here and i think again
parents have this opportunity to
to to embrace these these scripture
verses
and to reaffirm that you know what son
jesus loves me
and he forgave me and you know what
there's nothing that you can do that he
can't forgive you
too and when a father exemplifies that
when a child is really bad and
yanked a handful of his sister's hair
out you know the you know to show
the son how to go through the process of
repentance and forgiveness
i think it's also important to show your
children that you
do make mistakes we all make mistakes
and what do you do when you make a
mistake
how do you rectify that how do you come
back and that god will take you back and
so for you to
admit i messed up i did it wrong right
here
you know i have a part to play in
whatever has resulted
um and i'm sorry for that i think that
that that verbalization of that
also helps the children say oh well then
you can ask for forgiveness and god can
actually
you know it's practical christianity
scotty it's practical christianity
you're teaching your children
how to have a relationship with god and
to teach them that when you mess up
that you get back up and you can come to
god as you are and he promises to fix it
yeah i love that so my the last verse or
next the last verse that i want to share
is
psalms 139 again verse 14 i will praise
you
for i am fearfully and wonderfully made
your works
are marvelous they're not just good
they're marvelous
and that my soul knows it very well
when you say a verse like this guess
what i can't reject my biology
and when we're talking about
transgenderism we're not talking about
somebody that
was born with a birth defect and you
know what we live in a world of sin
six thousand years of degeneration there
are lots of people
that were born with ambiguous genitalia
or deformed or whatever
people born without arms without legs
and we know that we live in a world
where where where sin has been
developing or whatever
but when you're talking about somebody
transgender they're completely male
or completely female we're not talking
about anything in between
we're talking about a psychological
rejection of
that biology and so when you add this
verse to that a little child that may
struggle
with identity but when you have the same
sex parent affirming that child
and drawing them into that identity then
you back it up with the fact that jesus
you know knows that you were meant to be
this little boy and that he fearfully
and wonderfully made you
you know then you have another
affirmation and and
use what i what i noticed from you candy
is like you have like one
idea and you think that a lot of that is
based on that one idea
but none of us are just one idea we are
so complex
that we have many influences not just
how we were raised
not through those christian principles
that we did or didn't get along the way
but we have many areas that affect how
we shape our identities and our
personalities
and this is just another affirmation of
that what you get from your parents what
you get from your brothers and sisters
from your teachers from the people in
school so if teachers
and the church and the families all had
this resource
imagine the way that we could help to
affirm and to build healthy identities
in our children growing up along the way
wonderful
okay last verse psalm 139 verse 15
my body was not hid from you when i was
made in secret
you knit my delicate inward parts
together in my mother's belly
i am fearfully and wonderfully made
isn't that beautiful
oh and look at this last one remove all
my sin
and lead me to heaven that's how it ends
that's something remove
all my sin and lead me to heaven even my
thoughts can be wrong
even my thoughts can be simple and
understanding the creative and the
blessing
that god has put inside of each one of
us through our biology
it makes sense that mentally or
psychologically we may
separate from the intention of god that
he gave to us in our identities in our
bodies
but god can bring it all back together
isn't that cool
mike what a great conversation today so
from what i'm hearing from you
is there is no time that they're too
young you are actually teaching and
training
even though you may not talk about the
mechanics of sexuality
you're affirming in the way that you
just
you know interact with your children and
the things that you talk about
and through those more complex
conversations they get older
you're then teaching them really the
true model of sexuality yes yes and yes
and and i think that um the sooner
parents realize that you're teaching
your children about sexuality and
identity
from the moment that they're born you
know when a little sister is watching
you change little brother's diaper
you can point out the differences and
that's not a sexual thing and
that's not going to awaken some
sexuality in your kid but it's just
going to say
you know it's just like the dog that
wasn't neutered that runs around in the
backyard what are those mommy well you
explain
you know well you know the girl doesn't
have that the boy does
all of that in its in its biology
is not a dirty thing that's the what
life is and it's a beautiful opportunity
to start instructing our kids from the
earliest time that they notice that i
like your story scotty that
you know you came home and you're asking
your parents all these questions because
you were ready you were ready to know
more and you were inquisitive and that
should not be squelched
when a child is in quit inquisitive and
has questions
they deserve to know the answer and they
shouldn't be put off like
well i'm your father or it's not time
for you to know that or whatever
let them know what they need to know so
that they can understand
the question so that they're not seeking
somebody outside of the home to get the
information from yeah
i think you're also affirming the bible
along with this
you know it's it's this is the book we
go to to get our answers
and the answers are there and
you know with the abundance of answers
that are out there those answers are
essentially denying the validity of
scripture
and they are essentially saying that
what god did he did in error
you know and then from that point
if if god is wrong or in error
where do you go then for any other of
your problems
wherever you want yeah and you certainly
don't go to god because
he didn't do things right from the
beginning anyway
and then you know then you know that
leads to a whole multitude of other
issues like
now what do i do with my sin it takes me
back to that quote what you said
if you can't trust god then you're up to
trusting whatever you want
whatever somebody else says whatever
contract you can create and
and so i'm going to bring this back to
something that that um i shared
um just recently but i was at this
freedom march
and it was a group of 500 people that
were all together
and and we were um all sharing how god
had led us out of the lgbt lives
over 500 individuals right and yet even
in my own denomination
i couldn't find that kind of of unity
we were all unified on the word of god
which is what you're talking you know
about
everything has to do with our
relationship with god and
and every aspect of our lives when we
show our children that god is good and
that he's loving and kind and it is
truthful and it's
and it's something that you can rely on
and it's uh immutable it doesn't change
then that's what i experienced at this
group the freedom march where there were
over 500 people of
multiple denominations but we were
standing on the same verses and we were
all
in perfect unity i believe that that's
what god is looking for
in our parents as well as our churches
and our schools don't you think
amen i think that the little curriculum
there is beautiful and
it's you know really has all the
important foundational principles for
the kids to learn along the way
and you know as they get older and ask
questions you give them
the age-appropriate responses you know
30 minutes a day for five days is what
this is
i love it super cool i love it when's it
when's it gonna be
like a book or a little booklet i can't
believe that you said that but um
and especially as a parent i really
respect that that that's your um
that that's beneficial to you because
i'm not a parent and i've
never been a parent but um i really feel
for children that struggle with
identity issues because of my own
experience um but we are working on a
resource
awesome to have this okay yeah i want to
call a daughter's school
awesome all right well we hope that you
guys are blessed by today's talk
i know i certainly was and um if you
want to look more into mike's ministry
coming out
ministries.org right and
mike's got a lot of valuable resources
on there but thank you for coming
and we hope that you guys like this
video share it with anybody that you
think would benefit from this topic
and we'd love to hear your comments
about this god bless
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
visit our brothers at school for
prophets.tv and watch from babylon to
america which has over 5 million views
on youtube alone
and follow it up with america 2 babylon
check the description below for links to
this and more
[Music]
you